this is an eight news now breaking news  alert  some breaking news we're following right  now metro police investigating a crash  that happened near sahara and las vegas  boulevard  you are taking a live look at the scene  from a fast cam  you can see police right there in the  middle of the intersection looks like it  is still blocked off there  we can tell you one person was hit and  taken to the hospital where they later  died  that area is close to traffic as you can  see so we do have a crew on the way  we'll bring you the latest as we get it  those are all the details we have at  this hour  unfortunately that one person did die  there near sahara and las vegas  boulevard